[Music]
believe it or not it's been 25 years
since Billy Ray and his mullet hit the
scene with achy breaky heart just a few
months before Miley was born now he's be
releasing the single on iTunes even
doing a version in Spanish oh that's
good oh yeah yeah okay thank you well
you've got me to do it you also feel
like it kind of parallels what we were
in the world 25 years ago and us being
where we are in the world today when you
look at America and our world 25 years
ago and the divide there was a great
division not only in America but
worldwide you look at it today and in
some ways it's unfortunately that too
has gone full circle and Achy Breaky was
always about uniting people a bridge to
bring people together the Cyrus family
is busier than ever
Miley and Noah have new music Tish and
brandy are launching a new interior
design show
Cyrus versus Cyrus you're gonna make an
appearance on the show I have a couple
of them yeah you know hard to a couple
how are you guys doing cuz you you've
had this really nice we're in the
funnest place man you have just reached
this place looking at again you together
not so oh we're so together oh gosh
you're so good oh yeah yeah
so to go and it's so good like I think
you know sometimes sometimes you have to
evaluate you know where you've been
where you're at and where you're going
and yeah you know we we kind of took a
look at our gosh man we did all this and
came all this far to just say you know
that it didn't mean anything but when we
said no no no the other option is man
let's be stronger and we like that like
the stronger thing that that kind of
turned us on to like we don't look at
our family
everybody's happy they need us yeah
we're mom and dad